is not available for showmaker continues
to step forward one funds mystic shots
don't fight the targets he's shut down
the dragons going low it's picked up by
shooting they get themselves the sole
part of
the fight that's a flash forward there
is a reason that he has
style in his name as he is styling
all over damn one ben sentinel
gets caught up that's the quadra looking
for it ben we'll pick it up
get the pen to kill
oh that's a big rude the flamethrower
comes out cleanses well
flash forward 100 hp turning the damage
back up to one front
teleport's come out on fox heal and
flash has already been used the comet
spear comes out from beryl
first blood and today down one gaming
will
shut down sooning dom one will silence
shanghai and darwin gaming
are your season 2020 world
champions
[Applause]
now that is more like it that was a
good world finals the best one since
2016
surely in the history of worlds at first
it was korea that dominated then china
brought it out with europe and came out
on top and now with dam one gaming
winning
has korea returned to the throne the
answer is
nobody really knows and that might be an
amazing thing for league of legends
[Music]
alright guys really quickly i'm gonna
point you towards that subscribe button
if you haven't subscribed already you
can also let us know in the comments
section
what kinds of videos you want to see
next on the channel or you can email us
at tips the score dot com there was a
time
not too long ago when you didn't need to
know much about league of legends to
guess who would win worlds
it was probably going to be a korean
team in worlds 2017
samsung galaxy beat skt1 in the finals
the fall of the skt dynasty dominated
headlines
but it had also been the exact same two
teams in the finals for two years in a
row
in fact from 2015 to 2017 only one
region appeared in the finals korea and
of that
only three unique orgs if you compare
that to the last three years
there have been three different regions
and six unique orgs
back then we had become used to this it
seemed like the exact same story
every single year teams from all over
the world would battle it out but it
seemed inevitable that the summoner's
cup
would be returning to korea fans even
began to dub worlds as simply
lck fall season and to be honest it
might as well have been
with no korean team making worlds finals
for two years straight
it seemed like those days were long gone
but one team
seemed to deny the narrative that career
had fallen off
dam one gaming although their spring
2020
had been a bit lackluster it all seemed
to come together for summer they went on
a
16 and two rampage eventually
demolishing drx in the finals to become
one of the
favorites to win worlds 2020 and that's
exactly what they did
people who have watched competitive
league of legends for a long time are
always very quick to jump
back to this era of dominance that was
five world championships in a row the
last three of which
were between korea korea the both teams
in the finals the difference here
is that this was clearly dom one as
far above the rest of the world as they
were above the rest of the lck
because you mentioned only the few
losses here at worlds they only had a
few losses in the entirety of the lck
for the entirety of summer uh so i think
that is a big differentiator here
a korean team has won worlds once again
but the one thought i had while watching
dan juan
lift that trophy was not how strong
korea was
but how strong dam one was their 3-1
victory of assuming esports involved a
masterful control over objectives
as they successfully staved off
sunning's aggression
and slowly pulled them apart across the
map i just started writing them off but
here
come the damn one that's the engage from
marguerite
everybody on sooning is low the barrel
is danced away from by
canyon a double kill for beryl and angel
is running for his life
the series looked close after sooning
took game two
but damon just stepped it up a whole
gear in game four
to silence any claims that they want the
best
team in the world right now the other
two korean teams just
didn't seem to come close to dam one's
level
damwan had swept aside drx 3-0 in
quarters
and g2 had done the exact same thing to
gen g
while many will use danwon's victory as
proof that korea has returned to
contending for the title
it looked to me like only dam one
deserves that badge
when you reach that level the diamond
has there's no bands that are going to
push them out of the game there's
nothing that you can really really
target
diamond is a very very well-rounded team
and when you begin to look at these
band-aid solutions that we maybe saw in
playing so maybe in group state
pick the horn for simplicity when you
want to beat a team like taoman you
can't look for band-aid solutions you
need to have
everything down to the pin the rx had
one string with watch which was the
early game and maybe they could piece it
together
but even that was something that diamond
had full control over through their
bands because the rx
didn't have as much flexibility like a
dumb one this was a team
apart from the rest and there are other
similar stories
too of teams being head and shoulders
above their regions
is europe good enough to win worlds or
is it just
g2 and fnatic and although china
undoubtedly has
a deeper pool of contenders perhaps it's
time to start looking at teams
as individual entities whose fates are
not bound to the reputation of their
regions
teams can be strong regions are
officially
unpredictable apart from n a
of course good old reliable okay so
let's say
regions don't matter anymore and we
should set a team's expectations
based purely on how they play great
so what well if riot want their world
championship to be
more than just a world championship in
name only
then they need more legitimate title
contenders
once upon a time it was only korean fans
that expected
or even demanded that their teams bring
home the bacon
over the past few years you can add
china and europe to that list too
dan juan blocked any talk of a new
chinese dynasty their victory told the
world that
even if your region has its ups and
downs a
team doesn't have to and by doing this
they have helped inject a
very important ingredient back into
international competition
mystery at its very core competition
needs an air of mystery in order to grab
people's attention
back in the day there was only so many
times you could watch the lakers or man
united win
before it just got boring to a wider
audience
that is why we dislike a one-sided
finals
that is why we love an underdog story
if anyone can easily guess the results
of a tournament
then it loses a part of its appeal
during the era of korean dominance the
guesswork
was pretty limited you knew a korean
team
was probably going to win worlds and
they were probably going to be called
skt sk have overcome
every challenge they are the undisputed
best team in the world the skt
[Applause]
the mystery for the rest of the world
became who can stand up to korea the
best
who can dodge a korean team in their
group who can take a
single game off a korean team and after
a while
these aren't very fun questions to ask
and while a handful
did go toe to toe with them over the
years the results generally felt like a
foregone conclusion
now don't get me wrong i absolutely
loved seeing korea play the game
at such a high level i just wish things
were more open back then
and it's a little bit ironic that it's a
korean team
damn one gaming that has made me feel
like things are more open again
we have really come full circle i feel
like a team's fortunes
aren't so dependent on the region
they're from and there's more
competition because of that
even the 2020 finals themselves are
evidence of this
i think we can all agree that was the
most competitive finals in
years not only did we have two
completely
new finalists from two different regions
for the
second year in a row it was a three one
that felt
extremely close when sooning's been
absolutely popped off on fiora and got
this pen to kill
it felt like we had a real series on our
hands
it's time warning on the full retreat so
fm hops over the wall finds himself a
route to tonight that means he cannot
interrupt anyone else he's being choked
melted he's done he's dead
that's it canyon's finished as well sofm
hops forward ghost flashes defensively
and rooted in place
bin center gets caught up that's the
quadra
looking for it ben we'll pick it up get
the pen to kill
for pin and soon in gaming in the world
championship final i want more of that
i don't want regional dominance to
return i want
fans to truly believe that a team from
their region
can win worlds that injects a sense
of mystery back into things that brings
a
real sense of global competition into
what is supposed to be the most
global of all competitions i'm glad
damon are keeping things
interesting i'm glad they have risen
above their region to show
that a team can make it whether or not
their region is on top
it's anyone's guess who will win worlds
next year and what region they'll come
from
and as a league fan that's incredibly
exciting
this year you think it was pretty pretty
good worlds but i'm not really sure
if you're being authentic with us
because i know that you have a team that
you like that went on six
i don't know what you're talking about i
don't think i caught that
um no i don't remember that at all
no no i actually supported dan one from
the start i think you got it all wrong
i've been um i've been a dan one fan saw
god at least
15 15 years 20 years maybe i've been a
damn one fan
it's just just the way it is you know
liar